[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous dans le cadre
de cinq à dix spéciales municipal nous
recevons ce matin paul saint-yves cause
brocheray c'est savoureux bonjour
bonjour vous êtes retraité tête de liste
de construire ensemble pour mieux vivre
au gros morne
pourquoi vous vous présenter et ben si
j'aime me présente c'est pour faire un
vrai changement aux commandes puisque
actuellement nous avons une municipalité
qui est à l'omi nous voulons un
changement profond augmente
ce changement devrait passer par croît
selon vous ce changement des eaux
je vais vous dire franchement que
l'engouement actuel est endormi puisque
nous voyons que hay absolument pas
d'activité sur le gone nous avons
pratiquement tout est fermé aux gones
nous avons l'église y est fermé il n'y a
pas de marché pas de zones artisanales
et encore depuis quinze jours la commune
n'a pas de ligne
du côté de la gendarmerie depuis quinze
jours la communauté noire
et donc on voit vraiment bien vraiment
les ogms et je pense à la municipalité
actuelle que j'ai soutenu ou de
l'élection du maire actuel ne répond pas
on avait souhaité alors justement vous
aviez soutenu gilbert couturier pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous présenter contre lui
alors eh ben exactement c'est parce que
je vois que rien rien ne se passe aux
gones il faut vraiment un changement
augmente et je dis à la population
gabonaise et je laisse je le dis avec
profond respect pour tous les gens du
monde ne il faut pas donner un mandat de
plus a eu beaucoup trop et augmente
c'est ça mais trop gourmand commune dans
un cimetière puisque si dans six ans
rien n'a été fait aucun dossier n'a été
présentée de nulle part ni auprès de
l'état ni auprès d'eux
du feder le feder c'est le fonds
européen de développement pour
l'agriculture et ce qui s'en suit est
rien à aucun dossier est sorti alors que
tous les trois minutes de france et de
navarre un dossier du feder et présenté
vers le web pour donner des subventions
alors que nous savons que il y en a
peut-être qui doit sa part andy cole
augment n'a pas d'argent mais si vous ne
présentez pas des dossiers et si que par
exemple il faut que pour faire un pour
faire vraiment un bon développement
il faut passer par l'état aucune com ile
de france et de navarre a de l'argent
c'est comme une association
donc il faut il faut déposer des
dossiers mais comme le feder il faut 10
% et quand vous possédez c'est une
propriété un endroit que vous avez si la
terre
cette construction si vous avez déjà la
terre alors vous n'avez rien à donner
les disposant donc vous avez
pratiquement l'offre le
les travaux seront faits directement sur
la page par le feder et bien entendu le
la cité m
souvent mais la met dans la poche pour
aider les communes aussi alors quelles
sont les grandes lignes de votre
programme qu'est ce que vous proposez
alors me coucherai et bien il y en a une
priorité absolue que que je dois dire
c'est que le gone nous avons exactement
l'église qui ferme et depuis combien de
temps
et en plus ce show surprenant pour ne
pas faire les travaux
pour ne rien faire pour rester statique
on a déclaré bâtiment historique
or l'église ne peut être encore pour le
moment patrimoine historique pour faire
l'inventaire du patrimoine historique
c'est comme il faut déjà être vraiment
deux dents dans la chose or c'est pas
parce qu'on a déposé un dossier en 2017
il faut dire le commander fait partie du
patrimoine historique
c'est comme si lorsque vous allez dans
une boutique eur à fin d'année ou au
début de l'année les magasins font
l'inventaire parce qu'il possède la
chaux dans les magasins les chaussons à
vue mais l'église ne possède être
l'église n'est pas n'est pas ne fait pas
partie des monuments historiques comme
il faut il faut aussi vous dites dans ce
que j'ai lu de votre programme vous
aussi recréer du lien social dans le dos
dans la commune pourquoi y en a plus a
absolument ya pas de ya pas de lien
social
la communauté de que par trois personnes
et trois personnes avec le maire et donc
tous les adjoints et je dépasse les a
tué les conseillers je sais pas s'ils
sont là toujours si son parti mais
toujours est-il la commune n'est pas
gérer parce que ce qu'il faut qu'on vive
il faut que la population sache on
n'élit pas qu'une personne c'est une
liste connelly et lui donc il faut que
tout le monde participe à la vie de la
communauté
or si ces trois personnes qui dirigent
la commune oui ne peut marcher
monsieur creuserait je vous remercie
bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes
[Musique]